LOUIS GRAY: Good afternoon, this
is Louis Gray here with
Google Developers Live.
I'm speaking with
Jonathan Barry,
developer advocate on Google+.
We're here to talk about
Google+ Hangout Apps.
Now you're going to be speaking
next week at Google
IO 2012, talking about these
Hangout Apps, and I recently
saw you do a broadcast
on YouTube
previewing this session.
So I wanted you to have an
opportunity to give us an
intro to Google+ Hangout Apps.
What you guys are looking at,
and really tell us the state
of that platform today.
JONATHAN BARRY: Great, yeah,
so thanks Louis.
Thanks for having me.
Hangout Apps have been in public
availability for about
three months.
When we launched Google+ we
launched with Hangouts.
And the first thing we saw was
people using Hangouts in
creative and interesting ways
that we never foresaw.
And so immediately our first
reaction was we need to build
a platform for the platform.
So we launched Google Developer
Preview for the
Hangouts Apps.
And ever since then, developers
in the community
have been building.
And out the gate we
launched several
interesting Apps with partners.
And I'll be talking more about
what we've been doing with
Hangout Apps, the platform,
and giving some
demos at Google IO.
A few weeks ago we did a
recording about the 101 level,
the introductory stuff,
to getting started
with Hangout Apps.
It's actually really easy
to get started.
That's sort of the takeaway
of that whole thing.
And we have developers around
the world who are just jumping
on and building really fun and
interesting Apps using that
technology.
LOUIS GRAY: Now I've
gone ahead.
I've been a user of Hangout
since they first came out.
It's been fun to watch
those apps roll in--
from playing cards to drawing
silly little faces.
I know we're going to
move beyond that.
I know we had a lot of questions
come in from people
around the web.
We put them in through
Moderator
as well as on Google+.
I wanted to go through those
questions that have come
through and have
a conversation.
So one of the questions that
came in from Scotland, they
were talking about the
opportunity for applications
to send anonymous users
to a Hangout.
If an application authorizes
a user with a third party
service, like Twitter for
example, and wants to send
them to a Hangout without
the need to register.
Is this possible?
Perhaps we could have different
options whether
they're able to create
or join.
JONATHAN BARRY: That's an
interesting question.
So in terms of what we foresee,
we really don't
comment or speculate on rumors
when it comes to features.
But that's a great piece
of feedback.
Google+ itself is about identity
and being who you
are, and sharing who you
are, on the web.
So in the foreseeable future,
I think we're going to keep
with that model, where to take
advantage of the Google+
experience, you really need
a Google+ account.
Now there's nothing to stop you
from having an application
with your own third party
identity system, and
redirecting people to Hangouts
and have them log in.
There's also a log in flow if
they're not logged in already.
But that's really core to the
Google experience to take
advantage of everything.
LOUIS GRAY: What do you think
about options coming up,
possibly in the future, about
customizing the entry to an
application?
One of the developers was saying
what he wants to do is
present the users
with a button.
And once authorized, they can
be sent directly to a
configured Hangout.
For example, not having
the Invite Landing and
Configuration screen.
JONATHAN BARRY: So we have some
of that already today.
It's called the Hangout
button.
And it's basically an image,
a URL, which you
can put on your site.
You can put it anywhere
on the web.
That will launch a Hangout.
And you can do two things
with that button.
You can launch a brand new
Hangout, and just have it be a
new Hangout.
So if you just want to have
users communicate.
Or you can pass in a Hangout
to prepopulate.
You can also pass in metadata
with that Hangout.
So if you're on a sports team's
page, you can say I'm
on the blah football team and it
will actually load the app
with that configuration
information.
LOUIS GRAY: Now one of the
questions that came in--
Google has a lot of different
services and Apps and APIs
that we've rolled out.
So often people want
to know how they
interact with one another.
So we know Google+ is new.
Hangouts are a little bit
even newer than that.
Especially with the API being
rolled out, people want to
know how is that going to
integrate with things like
Google Web Toolkit?
This is something a lot of
developers out there are using
and are excited about.
How do you see these two kind
of technologies either
complementing each other
or working together?
JONATHAN BARRY: That's
a great question.
If you watch the video that
I recorded the other week,
Hangout Apps are just
JavaScript, HTML, CSS--
the power of the web in
tools you like to use.
So if you built an application
using the Google Web Toolkit,
there's nothing stopping
you from rendering that
application as a Hangout App.
In fact, there's a developer
in Japan, Aki Miyazaki, who
built a wrapper for
the Hangouts API
using Google Web Toolkit.
So definitely check that out
if you're interested.
LOUIS GRAY: Now I'm
a big Android guy.
You can tell.
I've got the shirt on.
I've got the Android
figurines.
I've been using Android
probably since 2.1.
I would've gotten there
earlier if I could.
But a lot of people have
questions around the different
versions of Android, and what
that does to impact the type
of apps that we're building.
So one of the questions
was around the
Google+ Hangout API.
How can it be used
with Android?
Is there any kind of difference
between say, Ice
Cream Sandwich, which is the
latest version, or pre Ice
Cream Sandwich devices?
JONATHAN BARRY: So first and
foremost, Hangout Apps don't
run on mobile.
So they're currently limited to
the browser-based Hangout
experience.
And we've heard from a lot of
developers they would love to
build the similar types of web
based applications inside of
the mobile app.
And that's just not on our
roadmap right now.
We're definitely exploring
different possibilities around
that, but then the differences
between the different Android
versions become moot.
LOUIS GRAY: That's definitely
something we look at.
You talk about developing for
mobile, developing for the
browser, I know we have a lot of
folks to make sure we have
a great Google+ experience
on mobile.
We see that improving
every day.
And I can see, even with
Hangouts, it's becoming even
easier to join or start
Hangouts as that goes.
I know a lot of people are
really hoping to see that
change, and find ways to get
Hangout APIs and Hangout Apps
working on that screen.
One of the thing I take a look
at is, when you're in a
Hangout you have all these
different options for
different apps.
Are there ones that come to mind
that you see people are
really gravitating toward?
How are you finding the type
of face to face experience
that's available on a Hangout
really making the application
that much stronger?
JONATHAN BARRY: So first I'd
like to touch about what makes
Hangouts really interesting and
fun and why we're seeing
such a spike in usage.
It's a piece of technology that
helps you do something
really meaningful and
gets out of the way.
Once you're in the video chat,
you no longer realize you're
chatting on a laptop
with a camera.
But you're communicating with
a friend or stranger or
somebody who's really
interesting.
And then Hangout Apps, the ones
that really excel, are
those ones that are not an
experience in and of
themselves but makes
the experience of
connecting even stronger.
So our favorite App, and the one
we actually developed at
Google, is the Effects App.
It started with a
simple mustache
for Movember in November.
But now we've expanded to crazy
things like birthday
hats and NASA helmets
and snorkels.
And so that's the type of
application that is not, in
and of itself, a destination.
But it's part of
the experience.
LOUIS GRAY: Right, and
one person was asking
about Native Client.
Native Client, obviously, is a
place where people are looking
for development especially
when it hits the web.
And Chrome's been talking
a lot about it.
When is that planned to be
released for Hangouts?
JONATHAN BARRY: Similar to the
Android response, I would say.
Right now the Hangouts rely on
the Google Talk plug-in which
most Google users already
are taking advantage of.
So it just updates seamlessly.
When it comes to porting that
over a native client, that
would be very interesting.
And we think there's definitely
room to explore there.
But right now the plug-in does
work, and as that native
client matures we'll
revisit that.
LOUIS GRAY: What is it about
Hangouts, and Hangout Apps
specifically, that make you
excited as a developer
yourself and excited to speak to
developers about what they
can do with Hangouts?
What is it specifically?
As opposed to looking at other
places to spend their time and
put their code.
JONATHAN BARRY: That's
a great question.
Personally, I'm a
web developer.
I love JavaScript.
I love HTML.
I love CSS.
And I like building web apps,
especially games and
interactive utilities.
The best part of Hangouts to me,
and what developers love
about it, is it's
just the web.
It's in iFrame.
It's your code that you can
host from anywhere.
You can put in on our server,
so you can take advantage of
our hosting.
But you can use all the
tools that you're
really comfortable with.
So that's the programming
languages for the backend
development like [INAUDIBLE],
like Ruby, like App Engine.
All the databases you
like to use and the
IDs you love to build.
So now you can build apps that
are really easy and really
leverage the power of the web.
But the extra, and the cherry
on the cake, is the
power of real time.
The video, the audio, component
and the APIs we
provide make for a rich
synchronous experience that
you can't find anywhere
else on the web.
LOUIS GRAY: Talk about finding
things anywhere else, when I
look at Google one of the things
that's really cool
about this place is we
have a lot of users.
And they're all over
the world.
And when you look at supporting
all these different
users, with different
geographies, and different
languages, there are things
that come up like
localization.
So there's some questions that
came up around whether you can
localize the terms of service,
the privacy policy, support
information.
How much thought do we give,
when creating Hangout APIs or
even just the core Google+, if
you could speak to that in
terms of serving markets outside
of the standard North
America and Europe.
JONATHAN BARRY: That's
a great question.
It's actually very timely.
This morning we launched the
ability to localize the title,
description, and icon for
your Hangout Apps.
I'm pretty sure this question
relates to that.
That's actually a pretty
good piece of feedback.
Right now most people surface
the terms of service, privacy
policy, and support page within
the application itself.
So you have control over that.
We'll certainly look at how we
can introduce the same level
of localization support for
those built into the package.
Hangouts themselves run in as
many countries as the Google+
can that we can legally
run it.
And so that means if you're in
Sao Paulo and Austria, you
could have a high quality
Hangout together.
Just as well as if you're
in San Francisco
and Mountain View.
And that, to me, is
Google scale.
An amazing technology that's
free for users.
LOUIS GRAY: So if we could
leave with one thing.
What is something that aspiring
developers should
know about Google+ that you
think most of them don't know?
JONATHAN BARRY: There's a lot
of stuff to talk about
Google+, but I would say that
there's a really strong
community around Google+.
And that means for developers
talking to other developers.
We're having our Google IO
conference just next week.
6,000 developers from around
the world coming together
learning about new technologies,
but also
communicating with each other,
socializing, networking.
And I find that there's a strong
developer community
within Google+.
I get to learn about new
libraries, new technologies,
new tools to help me be
a better developer.
So definitely check
out this growing
community within Google+.
LOUIS GRAY: All right,
well I appreciate you
taking the time Jonathan.
It really sounds like Hangout
Apps are taking off.
We're just at the beginning,
and I'm looking forward to
what's next.
And thanks for doing our Q &A.
JONATHAN BARRY: Thank
you Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: See you
at the Google IO.
JONATHAN BARRY: See
you at Google.